I wrote it I sent it I'm so it's my
senior year of college and I've got
really hot Saturday night plans order
Chinese takeout and then eat it I looked
in the bag and there was no four and
there were no chopsticks there was no
vehicle with which the Singapore rice
noodles could travel into my mouth so in
a blind rage I sent an email to what I
thought was my dorm hey guys does anyone
have a fork I can use but I sent it to
my entire school the backlash was
immediate ding ding ding everywhere I
have notifications telling me to go for
myself someone responded yeah I have a
fork you can use someone else responded
unsubscribe and that was a freshman who
responded that that is like an alpha
move then later someone posted is a
really necessary to email the entire
school about a fork which as you know is
the thing that I did that one got 200
likes and then somebody else responded
to it saying seconded literally just
saying I agree which is by the way what
a like does that got a hundred lights
people saw that first post and we're
like yeah man and then they saw that
second post that just said uh-huh and
they were like yeah I'm even better
so I guess my pro tip here would be if
you want to unite a lot of people send
them all an email they'll hate you but
they'll grow to love each other
you